[Music]
was it fun getting ready yeah what yeah
these guys are always salad that was
really fresh I mean they set the bar
pretty high I mean I was a little
intimidated
last year the SAG Awards I honestly
think that my favorite moment was the
acceptance speech by that day gave all
of you guys want I mean that was awesome
how are you gonna top at this tonight I
don't know if we win if you're talking
again cuz he better yeah I know
jump around again oh you guys get to
celebrate afterwards you said you guys
like to have a good time I'm gonna go
out and get pizza and then go to my
hotel room and take a nice long nap
how about you are you gonna like
honestly that sounds I'd rather just go
hang out with friends you know party I
want to live my life you know I'm gonna
be a boring old person plenty of time to
be a boring old person saying the boring
old person out of the way now and so I
can be super exciting when I get old
you've never heard this question before
but what can you tease I mean we got to
wait so what do you know what you can
just give me like 80 I know you could
give me like specifics but come on man
yeah you see some scripts or no we're
told anything where would you like the
story to go
Dustin becomes a six-foot bodybuilder
and he become he gets like the Texas man
alive thing on People magazine and
everything no man it's coming